Chris waters have you my friend I'll
great Danny who are these fine gentlemen
between us it looks like it's eduardo
Ramirez the creator of Phoenix rage yes
and on his body Anthony ciao thank you
remember a name no I remember your name
that's wrong here's I wanted to rise you
early on just set the mood right you
know okay you guys releasing a video
game according to the steam page in 21
hours yes exactly how's that feel up
awesome but yeah little nervous yeah you
doing the rounds today checking out
everyone showing off the game no we're
here just for you just for us you came
you guys keep all the way from Costa
Rica just to show us this great video
right all right are you jumping in
straight away just playing some soccer
and what are you doing speaking French
all done what the world cup and this is
a bit oh yeah actually I made this game
because of the results results are okay
yeah all right I want to fight with that
like yeah I have to make a mini game
both football he's a great turnaround
it's like two months yeah to get it out
nice work yeah yeah you got you've been
working on this for a much much longer
time than not and yeah and what I like
is when we came on the stage at e3
clearly as the creator of the video game
you have a certain demand of the ability
and this is not a game there's
particularly easy no which is why you
bought Anthony because he sucks yeah
okay thanks just wants to make it seem
approachable by putting a the common to
low skilled gamer okay pretty much
behind the controller that work so yeah
we're actually showing off here is
something we just want to warm up a
little before we get in the main game
this is like the mini arcade games that
are featured in Finnish free we call
these keepy uppies in Europe keepy-uppy
yeah so I scored nine but so you're
supposed to keep the ball you know
supposed to I keep the ball up as long
as you can and each time you do it with
a dash and get a score okay so keeping
it up ain't hard you know I can go yeah
it's like oh yes a [ __ ] it's a lot more
easy sorry oh ok it's gonna say you know
the moods not right no maybe not much of
a looker let's go hit the pants i got if
you're just had a long day yeah and
speaking which we are giving away copies
of phoenix rage on the show today so if
you want to win a copy of phoenix rage I
just say in the comments Cynthia's
keeping an eye on those and we'll give
them out as well as a bunch of other
stuff once the demo is done and dusted
awesome all right
how many you got six guys 67 and these
are like this is one of nine yeah
whatever I like our mini games that you
can just kind of play with him and just
kind of a mess around with you I think
you're better at this than I am I am I
hate 11 burning aigo aigo 13 so and that
as you get how you get in the morning
higher numbers come out and stuff costs
on average alright this looks easy in
comparison to the game to the game yes
yes it's a warm up so why don't we just
jump into the game are you portal for
all you want but now yeah not that you
need to go yeah and I'm the one that
release anthe is looking pretty cold
it's probably getting him in there and
not 21 he was on purpose okay sorry
let's move the game okay so what we're
going on a straight demonstrate our a
couple of Eduardo's favorite level okay
and I'm gonna play it through and show
you how Joe average places like them and
then where I show a mastermind like I do
that as crap so as you can see at the
dodge and go through they have different
portals you'd go to different things
it's you know this is pretty much a
hardcore plat for price I was playing
stayed about an error of this yesterday
at lunch time and got maybe five levels
and I'm sure you hear this comparison
non-stop but I'm gonna say it anyway it
did give me that super meat boy each of
its difficult but it's the controls are
tight so that I feel like it's me that's
messing up and it's not the game being a
jerk so I kept playing kept trying to
beat the levels yeah but even this looks
like way miles hard and what I was
experiencing at you and I'm gonna make
myself 25 tries because otherwise we'd
be here forever shut up Chris just
waiting until they like late in the
evening you finally pass one level you
know what within live streaming for five
hours okay you did get that cookie I'm
impressed that was that was nice move oh
mama tried then I'm gonna show it do i
do I this car oh I believe in you
Anthony I do I don't I go daddy yeah I
think he's here for the sole purpose to
not do this you think he has motivation
to fail oh no the cookie I'm getting
come on back on with fabulous okay for
they sing kee all right hey don't mess
it up all right I won't mess it up its
life its life isn't it oh we like we're
live oh yeah
CBS CBS news right now okay so that so
now all right I guess so now watch oh
whoops sorry I got a bunch of chivos on
my cash thank you so let's have a dry no
show off how it's really done so that
was a if you selected this on normal
what happens if what's the challenge
cherish mode actually limits the number
of jumps oh alright and number of jumps
and dashes so and once and what would
you like oh the final hurdle what yeah
yeah tell me that I'm a journalist is
live on CBS right hahaha Katie Couric
introduced this and after I feel like
you're the cranky coach who's just like
goading his player oh I am I am I'm not
champion better than s like like I'm
like the elephant ultimate back to Game
soo nice i got the picture yes I yeah
you're you are impressive at this game
yes okay so as if you made this game or
something okay so that's what harder
harder harder harder alright that's one
of harder okay hey real so you're saying
challenge restricts like the number of
jumps is there does will put a time
limit on there so other sort of stuff no
that's just the number of doesn't dashes
so once you've used up use that up then
yours yet start starting answer now this
is really hard so Eduardo do you I mean
do you set those numbers by basically
charting the optimal route through the
through the level and then deciding like
all these are where to put the challenge
bar uh uh yeah well I play but a lot of
time mmm yeah it was like a chicken walk
that kind of mouth bound because you
don't like do you make it the exactly
like precise minimum or at least
sometimes that you like to pull yourself
off some extra a little bit of leeway
yeah yeah yeah like this must be hard to
kind of like find where that spot is
yeah you know yeah you're right I got a
bunch questions coming in Red Hat true
on gates watch a task is their story in
Phoenix rage when two three well Phoenix
race is looking for revenge and we all
yeah real he's down got completely
destroyed and well you have to figure
out what happens that okay and I want to
play your discover
uh you know what happened mm-my
discovering god I'd you got a bunch of
cutscenes in between like the different
zones yes don't write yes okay who was
25 seconds of this nice work you and
suck that bad thanks Danny what the what
was that red bit that is I can order but
don't get that mean no no go beyond how
much time back it's basically a look at
the cook all right i'm not getting a
bouquet I'm getting too big the Red
portal is basically secret levels so I
think if you get in there and there's a
time limit if you get there you actually
see the prototype levels that were used
oh really oh really yeah and there's
like 20 in them and they're just as hard
this is terrifying me uh-uh that's a
great you know you think you're so good
got it is that's because he is is why he
thinks that you know what I'm just to
clarify no you're ever I mean whatever
whatever has sewn on twitch is wondering
what those small little birds do where
they kind of point you the direction to
go winners they're like hints okay but
not by renkens okay okay yeah yes follow
the birds son stop it
okay so all that environmental stuff is
you can kind of turn yourself flamey
they'll take out the ice puzzles and
stay we die actor is the bad guy has
like a shoulder and Phoenix is the fire
fire in this you know in this level you
have to you know set up in the fire and
keep yourself in fire decide if i get
the ice ray egg I don't get a cookie
atomic so you did a fastener so what all
about the cookie oh you know cookie a
metaphor uh kind of figure it out for
yourself yeah yeah by the game there's a
reason they have a reason okay and
Bulbasaur babe is asking who did your
sand track some great music on my
brother-in-law really yeah how BIG's
it's a mess you made it and no it's josé
Mota a volte made all the sounds in
sound check really yeah has he a history
of doing like digital music up yeah like
yeah for a while yes that you're like
mom write the story and your browser
actually I have to change the story
because my I didn't like my mom wrote it
right yeah it's not watching it I know
okay this is actually one of the boss
level so we're showing off a boss right
here yo attack its weak point for
massive damage I solution to all life's
problems day Danny's like I need to go
grocery shopping this weekend I really
don't have a lot of food starts looking
for weak points to attack for massive
damage why don't have food in the first
name oh uh uh Maria and BT Thames bdd
Tampa is asking more platforms this will
be on your on PC tomorrow but that's
coming in console as well right it's
going to playstation 4 and xbox one cool
yep any any time on those bad boys early
early 2015 all right and is there
multiplayer at all any co-op stuff for a
leaderboard scoreboard kind of very
bored all I know for sure I mean this
game was made for
speed round yeah i mean ashley eduardo
just added a new feature a couple days
ago where you press the white button it
actually resets the game to this its its
original state level original state for
speed right so like oh right so your
Otis yeah if you're a speedrunner and
like you say you're messing up messing
up halfway and you press the white
button and you'll be starting to pee
because when you die it just responds
you never spot game is still playing
yeah yeah okay this is yeah whatever if
you fall and hit the ground while iced
will you like quatre t1000 style no
you're fine you're fine that would be
it's gonna take more than oh I thought
you were good I knew that it was oh yeah
whatever it's game time man do all the
training you want if you can't pull it
off one tip don't clear it free I'm all
thing I've all found exact oh I both
thing with the eyeballs are you oh oh
shut up mm-hmm just squeeze one of these
here yes we don't that yeah we make
yourself feel better yep are the other
characters in the game at all different
abilities or well God we want to include
in the future more like hints or more no
different yeah but it's definitely
that's definitely be DLC and we know
we're still in the kind of planning
phase for that but for now it's just it
just being spurned mr. rage himself and
thur Bolton's wondering what color blind
players have any issues with this we get
that question all the time really yeah
it's a lot of folks there are a lot of
in color why players at one point the
game spot editorial staff was like one
third color really yeah um I don't think
that's that's a very good question ah
the flames seem to be on like have
animation they do that a lot of blocks
do so I I don't think they would have a
issue but I mean it you know are you
know yeah it was hard what's wrong in
fact you know what let's go to the
hardest moments how we doing on time
time yeah I keep going ok ok I want to
see some more what you want to see some
more levels and I'm not gonna get you
this day one of the this sanctuary this
world mine so you're gonna see some
really effort how many worlds are there
there are nine world over 200 life oh my
god oh jeez this is some hot [ __ ]
how mad that's too little demon snakes
see this is a level where I just be like
no different time I got a cookie
somewhere else we must get back yeah ah
this reminds me of playing like Stardust
and stuff we're at a certain point
you're not even looking at the level you
just you you know the place to go to
just do it and I even like you're almost
on autopilot yeah before I was getting
to the point where you know they were
sort of at that level where they were
all hovering upwards it got me to that
point where you're sort of abstract your
vision yeah right where you're just
you're not read it you're it was not
reading to get what I looked at him to
any other cookie I have you done it
replay replay replay replay oh no you
just play it again ok you'll see how you
guys ok see how will he do this really
quick I can't look at crisler Shh son oh
and over Hammond just keep running with
the lives of the snakes forever no don't
come with to do Chris ok just a
suggestion it's not in a good place are
you think I know it's gonna be on twitch
like all week just people friggin Santa
I really want to see that yeah yeah I've
you shopped it around what you'd like em
expose and stuff because if we made you
an e3 but we were packs no taxes yeah I
PAX East here so what's I'm like getting
a devil's hands there either folks you
just want to stay and keep ya trying to
drive right at me nothing i'm talking to
you to try and throw you off
yeah it seems like a see it's not that
easy isn't twitter dreams of this would
be a great way to pick up some new
expletives there you go that's a new
frustrated shouts of pain and agony this
is logged on to my steam account as well
so I'm just breaking them up oh yeah
everyone's gonna be super how did he do
that five seconds is really good one day
and they see her look for weeks atomic
what are white people and sick in the
comments if you want to win a coffee
Phoenix rage we're giving away 5 during
this demo laughing [ __ ] Scott mm-hmm
oh god I guess can do it you can do it
shut up your positivity doesn't help
don't shake your head I can see you
shake your head under water I'm
disappointed look that's all there is to
it I thought you were gonna do better
yeah how many more tries are you gonna
give yourself up stop it over the yajes
we got it I got this is the one this is
that you got it you got it this one yeah
god damn it classic water told you not
to bring chow classic Jack I sucks i
know god unbelievable got damaged all
right for the folks at home how much
does it have winds it available tomorrow
tomorrow 20 hours from now yes hey good
any good I can't do three I could juggle
let's say I can I juggle too all right
you could do it it's available tomorrow
on steam oh my god Artie I think a dry
one immediately 4910 sweet oh great how
can you juggle it all of course of
course of course yeah I can do that
whatever ha lemon that's pretty good
haha huge or tears like you sure what
you're going on thank you that's to look
at Phoenix rage and yeah yeah talk to
you soon enjoy watching people suck at
your game on twitch next 48 hours until
this are getting good again